so can I turn to Lord Clement Jones
first thank you very much indeed Chad
good morning
um and I'm going to start off with a
very broad uh General uh question to
start with
um what do you see as the greatest
possible benefits and most pressing
concerns associated with autonomous
weapon systems uh which no doubt we will
shorten to AWS uh throughout our uh
discussion today can I start with you
Charlie
certainly so first I'd like to thank the
committee very much for having me here
as a witness I'll keep my remarks as
short as possible to allow as many
questions as possible
I represent the office for disarmament
Affairs so naturally our focus is more
on the concerns presented by military
use of AI including AWS and while it has
been argued that there could be
improvements in accuracy or reductions
in collateral damage
this has not yet been demonstrators and
I would instead point to the potential
impacts that Verge more on the concern
side so some of these include things
like AI applications in the military
domain may lead to International
instability they have the potential for
introducing elements of unpredictability
at times of international tension and
they can lead to actions that are
difficult to attributes and I think
difficulty of attribution is an element
that is likely to come up uh frequently
today creating risks for
misunderstanding and unintended
escalation which I think you can also
agree is a serious concern AI
Technologies do have the potential that
they could Aid decision makers by
allowing faster real-time analysis of
systems and data and providing enhanced
situational awareness however this
presents its own concerns it may
compress the decision-making time frame
and also lead to increased tensions
miscommunication misunderstanding
including particularly for miles is
concerned between nuclear weapon states
which introduces another Dynamic that we
would be significantly concerned about
all uses of AI in military contacts
present concerns regarding
predictability and the Black Box nature
of the technology makes this
particularly relevant for AWS
so one element I would especially like
to underline is the importance of
effective testing evaluation
verification and validation in this
context and demonstrable reliability all
of these are essential before deployment
and while there is a general acceptance
among civil and Military responsible
development practices that AI should be
robust for which we also mean reliable
and safe from a technical standpoint the
necessary testing evaluation
verification and validation to ensure
this is a particular challenge for AI
related Technologies in a military
context and especially for AWS so how
could we actually ensure that any
testing we carried out did sufficiently
meet those criteria
this is both because it is not currently
clear that there are any proven
effective methods for testing
non-deterministic but this I mean less
predictable and more adaptable systems
like one would hope AWS would be
where runs the same test may not
generate the same results the
differences between the testing
environment and the deployment
environment can cause unpredictable
outcomes once deployee changes in the
data or on the algorithms themselves can
also lead to changes in Behavior
presenting still further challenges
I'll finish my remarks on this with just
one quick more point which is there is
also the broader issue that some AI
related Technologies are relatively
easily acquirable by non-state actors
and so may be employed in weapons or
non-weapon related functions such actors
may not have the interest or even the
capacity if they did have the interest
to employ AI related Technologies in a
responsible Manner and from our
perspective that it particularly
includes protections for civilians
thank you very much I'm going to come
back later to tease out whether it's
essentially the autonomy or the
intelligence that's the issue but I'm
going to come to Yasmin yet next that
was quite a catalog Yasmine do you uh
agree with that yes so um I think that I
would equal a lot of the points that
Charlie made
um so first of all before we get into
the opportunities and risks I think that
we need to also bear in mind that we
need to broaden the scope a little bit
beyond autonomous weapon systems
um because Beyond autonomy as a function
I think that we also need to look at
artificial intelligence which is in line
with the committee's Mandate here today
and Beyond weapon systems I think that
um we also need to think about AI
enabled programs Beyond weapon systems
such as
software for example to enable strategic
decision making
and also those used across the targeting
cycle for intelligence collection and
making for example and in terms of the
key benefits I think that out there's 40
I would list but then obviously with the
caveat that the octave program works as
intended so first there's a increased
situational awareness as Charlie has
mentioned so we can have for example
software combining both data gathered
live from the battlefield
um combined with historical data and
also combined with success parameters
um it will not only increase situational
awareness but also increase chances of
mission success and then the second
better intelligence collection again
with the caveat that it all works as
intended and reliably third there's the
question of modeling you can use AI
enabled software for advanced synthetic
environment programs enabling advanced
war gaming we have in the UK for example
improbable defense that does a lot of
work in this um in this field that would
enable better training and planning
capabilities and then fourth the main
sort of Advantage I would say is speed
especially for time sensitive decision
making processes especially in the
nuclear realm but then again you have
all the risks Associated that Charlie
has mentioned and again at the risk of
sounding a bit um repetitive I think
that there's a question of
the risks and the assumption that the AI
is working as intended so in terms of
the risk I would outline for
um first is risk pertaining to the
overhype and um problematic and
misleading assumptions around AI we talk
about artificial intelligence so we have
this intelligence this construct that is
inherently based on a human trait but is
it intelligent
um and then I think that
link to that there's the issue of risk
perception and how it affects the way we
evaluate risks especially now with the
AI arms race Dynamic not only in just in
the security and defense sector but also
in commercial context we can see here
for example um with big tech companies
such as Google and Microsoft deploying
AI technologies that perhaps might be
premature in terms of testing and
reliable reliability evaluation at the
expense of robust and thorough safety
standards just for the sake of
commercial on cane and then there's the
issue of compliance with the law in
ethics which I think will cover a bit
more in detail later in the hearing
third is the integration of the systems
within established command control and
communication systems and couple with
that there's the issue of technical
literacy of the users of such Advanced
systems and then fourth is are the
technical issues that are more General
that may affect the reliability of the
system so for example algorithmic bias
Black Box the quality of training and
testing data sets and from this issue
naturally you would think of ethical and
legal and policy issues that will cover
later candidacy hearing there's I think
one of the interesting areas that you
covered there was the perception point
uh apart from the you know the reality
there is this issue about the perception
of uh uh AWS as well which is added to
all the concerns that Charlie mentioned
uh that um Charlie mentioned I'm going
to come to you about saw now
um do you agree broadly with those
benefits and and risks
uh thank you so much fun first of all
thank you for the opportunity to to give
evidence
um I would generally totally agree to to
what Charlie and Yasmine said um I took
your question very literally so I'm
gonna Focus mainly on the specific case
of autonomous weapons while I agree that
it's also important to consider the
military use of AI in general
uh so I guess I would like to start with
just a brief caveat and say that the
answer to your question the original
question about benefit and risk depends
partly on how one defines Optimus
weapons and as you may know there's a
lot of definitions out there uh the
working definition that we use at C3
recognize that what makes AWS so
distance
right we're definitely going to come to
that uh after this set of questions uh
on the risk and benefit and so on
um that's almost the next set of of
questions
sure
um but I just want to flag that one
element that is critical for that
question is the fact that it's not the
weapons that once activated you can
select and apply Force without human
intervention that's all the benefits and
risks in a way it's time from that very
defining characteristic the fact that
part of the targeting process is at
least part of it effect you know done by
the machine so in terms of benefit you
know you know when you talk to military
planners they would typically are like
five
it would allow you to for greater speed
you can you could execute Target tasks
much faster than if it was like a human
operated weapon and it's very
potentially useful for like very time
critical task like air defense or
air-to-air combat where human reaction
time might be too slow that's one two it
allows you with greater reach so you can
basically deploy in AWS in operational
theater where that is beyond Rich
because either it's communication denied
so you cannot go there with remote
control weapons or it's too dangerous
for a fighter aircraft to go for
instance that's two three it can provide
you greater persistence so the classic
argument that AWS performance is not
altered by things like fatigue boredom
hunger or fear so in a way like we could
you know the performance would remain
the same over time and which make them
very good for like missions are very
dull or dirty or dangerous uh like when
you have to kind of defend a specific
perimeter of a long time or track Target
over weeks or month
fourth grade Precision the idea that
potentially like Optimus weapons might
be more effective and discriminate than
if you are using a theory shells that
are unguided and the fact that
potentially they can pay more precisely
allow you to also reduce the payload so
that also could you know reduce the risk
of the quality all damage and five uh
the idea that it could allow you to
reintroduce better coordination and math
on the battlefield so this idea that
when Optimus weapons can operate as a
team as a football team basically they
can you can they can operate in a much
more coordinated way than if they are
they were all kind of human operated and
that's arguably would allow military to
reintroduce maths in the battlefield
where you can have a large numbers of of
small you know Optimus weapons
overwhelming uh defense responses so
these are like typically the benefits
that are highlighted by by mid-2 experts
then in terms of concern I think most of
my my colleagues will recover them I
would just pack them into categories the
first one other we would say the
humanitarian concerns and the fear that
AWS depending on how they are designed
and how they are used good exposed
civilians and protected people on the
IHL to greater risk and here the fear is
that resistance for instance would not
be reliable enough or they would spell
in a way that would
expose or civilians like it would
misidentify a civilian as a local Target
for instance
um or that the system would not be able
to recognize people that are called the
combat who are protected under HL uh but
there are also people that have this
kind of ethical perspective and say that
on that this period but have this view
that it would be morally wrong to have
an autonomous weapons to identify
military personnel on the battlefield
that it would be a violations of the you
know the combatants right to dignity uh
and that's that but that point is highly
contexted in in the in the in the policy
discussion
so that's for the humanitarian concern
and then the second package I would say
it relates to the most strategic level
concern I think these have already been
covered quite a lot
and Charlie I look up at the idea that
he could lower the threshold Advance
conflict and some states might be
incentivized to perhaps connect
operations that could lead to an arms
conflict because they feel like since
it's a robotic systems you know the
attribution will be harder
but I would Point here that it's not AWS
specific problem it's basically a
problem about robots in general
um then the speed there are the two key
things are the impact on the speed of
warfare and I think Charlie already
covered at that point that you know
that's the downside of having something
that allows you with faster reaction
time
and the risk of use by non-state actors
and I think the idea of this kind of
like low-tech uh autonomous weapons that
could be kind of like developed by
a terrorist group or people that are
just putting together Technologies from
the commercial sector is basically
something that is to be considered
over just before Lord Clement change
goes on can I bring in Lord Hamilton
he's got a point on on these issues well
I wanted to bring back the whole issue
of Egon musk yesterday I think saying
that he thought that the AI should be
paused I'd really like your views on the
viability of pausing the development of
AI and how would you get International
agreement that they had any sort of
liability in it at all
Charlie perhaps it's
that
that's uh not an easy one to volunteer
to answer so Charlie do you want to go
first
certainly um it isn't an easy one to
answer and I think the the call from
Elon Musk and some of the other
co-signatories is specifically relating
to functions around chat and similar
systems I think possibly the best answer
I can give here is to give one that is
almost an advertisement for the UN and
our general calls in this area which is
this really underlines a few issues one
is the Dual use nature of the technology
he's not calling for a pause necessary
in military development of AI it's
calling for a pause that relates to
private sector and general development
of AI that dual use nature of the
technology mean physicists of elements
have potential military impacts and they
also have obviously civilian economic
impacts
the key issue from a un perspective and
making any kind of pause or any kind of
international regulation viable is it it
has to be Universal so the private
sector Origins and the relatively low
bars to acquisition of AI applications
there's no real obstacle for anyone to
work on the development of AI or for
anyone to purchase the applications that
come out of the development of AI I mean
the only way to ensure effective
governance is through Arrangements that
are universally applicable and that are
developed through an inclusive process
and I think your question sort of
underlines that right that even if you
were able to get complete agreement from
every state it would need to be a
process that meaningfully engaged the
private sector Civil Society Academia a
huge range of stakeholders have any
meaningful impact so if you take that to
the narrower AWS context then we're
looking at what kind of international
regulation is possible who would have to
be consulted and who would actually have
to be party to some kind of agreement
there and I'll end my remarkably there
just to point also to the issue flagged
also by Volson which is this issue of
non-state actors so you would have to
have a situation in which non-state
actors accessibility or ability to use
these kinds of Technologies are also
meaningfully restricted which is where
the Dual use element becomes
particularly important because in
general the concern for non-state actors
is diversion and misuse but that they're
using civilian Technologies not
necessarily Technologies designed with a
military intent
and Versa and Yasmin are you broadly in
agreement to that
yes so um uh yes I'm sorry
yes win okay
I think that I would agree with the
points that Charlie made and I think the
letter um that came out yesterday was
really timely in the light of our
discussions today
um it's just that I have a few concerns
relating to the letter because first of
all I think that you know it's
commendable that they have set up this
really ambitious objectives into what
they're trying to achieve within this
six months moratorium that they're
calling for
um they are asking for safety protocols
and standards and also a rethink on the
risks associated with AI Technologies
but I think that first of all six months
is definitely not enough you have
ethicists lawyers Civil Society
academics and even
parliamentarians thinking about this for
years now and we haven't come up with a
solution so how how do you expect to
come up with robust
um safety protocols and standards within
six months when for years people who
have dedicated their professional life
and time that have not come up with a
solution but I think that what um what
is interesting from the letter and one
lesson that we could learn is the value
of slow AI compared to the arms race
dynamics that we're seeing at the moment
I am working on AI and I have a hard
time keeping up with the news I see chat
GPT gpt4 Bart um being developed in the
large language models realm and I can't
keep up
um so you know I think the value of slow
AI is that that I would allow us for
more robust and thorough so testing
evaluation verification and validation
processes that would enable the
incorporation of ethical and legal
standards within the development of the
systems
and something that I think uh
is would also be valuable from this sort
of slower approach to the developing and
deploying AI is that it would allow
space for an inclusive and
multi-stakeholder dialogue that would
inform the development of this AI
enabled Technologies because in the end
those Technologies are really powerful
um and fact is to develop and to conduct
research for advanced AI at least it
requires a lot of
um you know when you think about AI we
talk about non-state actors we think
about anyone who could do AI research
yes of course anyone can do AI research
and work on their computer but at the
same time if you want to run something
that is highly Advanced you need High
compute Powers you need Hardware you
need a lot of resources whether it's
Financial human resources and not not
everyone has it only a handful of
companies have access to this kind of
facilities and I think that from slow AI
what the value is is that we can also
rethink of the power relationship we
have vis-a-vis those powerful companies
that have the power to conduct this this
powerful AI it isn't that precisely the
problem I mean slow AI sounds a lovely
opportunity and we can all look around
and we can assess the situation as it
develops but the people who are
developing Ai and are putting huge
resources behind it it's not in their
interests to slow it up
um so that slow AI has just really got
to remain a bit of it's pie in the sky
isn't it
I I mean you know the thing is that you
can of course slow AI might not be in
their commercial interest but if we
think of ethical and legal requirements
it's also not in their interest for
reputational purposes but also for
liability purposes to develop something
that that further down the line have
such huge risk implications that it
might actually help hold them
criminally liable for um because they
were they for example they didn't take
into account the due diligence measures
they had to take to to go through for um
yes but if you can inject that into the
bottom line that's what uh commercial
developers are keen on
um if the possibility of criminal
sanctions or reputational damage is
something that they can see in economic
implication for then that might be a lot
more persuasive but I don't see the two
joining up somehow I think that's where
regulation could step in really and you
know we have this kind of multistake
today and
the end table also elsewhere and I think
if we have a think more closely with
this actors from the private sector and
also from um from the lawmaking
Community from the policy making
community and then from from from the
Civil Society organization side I think
there would be really big value in sort
of instilling this thinking
um this culture of responsible AI
um into the minds of those developing
those powerful AI Technologies
have you got anything to add to that
yeah I'll try to be brief since uh since
my colleague will recovered quite a lot
I was about three points obviously uh
the first point is about you know AI as
a category is not really helpful so it's
it's so Broad and so vague uh that
um it's difficult to Define what the
Contour of that sector there are so many
technologies that we may fall under that
definition so I think it's always
important to be specific about the type
of application or end use that we are
concerned with and as as my colleagues
mentioned that the the idea that was
discussed in the open letter was was
about this large language models like
scientific so that's a very specific
application first point number one thumb
number two I think is is the difference
between Innovation and civilian sector
and the military sector
but nothing to coming back to this idea
of slow AI the military sector is in a
way a slow sector to the extent that
they are legal mechanisms that slow down
the adoption or they are that they
require that if the states wants to
acquire AI for y-level military purposes
for instance it needs to go through a
legal review process where it will be
you know ensure that the system is not
prohibited on an international loans on
so they are like in a way safety
mechanism dating in the acquisition
process that that minimize the risk
while in when you get into the civilian
sector where regulations then is is you
know there's no International
regulations you know all from the
civilian side it's more the national or
Regional level as we see now with the
discussion in the EU about the EU AI act
and I think one of the difference is
that in the civilian commercial actors
have an incentive to come to Market very
quickly so while in the military sector
you know you are very mindful of the
possible risk of you know persistent
trailing for instance while in the Civil
sector like you have a you know it's
showing your advantage to be to come out
soon and to test the system and maybe
you have a system which is not and
that's that's the challenge I guess and
and perhaps the third point of final
point is about how do we build it and
deal with that and whether moratorium
can be a solution it could to some
extent but there are obviously
challenges with that as Jasmine
mentioned I guess one thing that may be
helpful to think for the regulation is
the idea that having a
technology-centric approach might not be
always helpful and rather than to to
focus on on Norms around what up you
know elements that needs to be
considered for the responsible
development and use of these
Technologies like General high level
principles that companies would need to
kind of
abide by as they are developing and
deploying these Technologies and I think
that's the more kind of future-proof way
of approaching this challenge rather
saying that we need to kind of isolate
this specific technology and determine
whether we can keep working on it or not
um do I try like to Define this high
level principle and then from there have
this kind of a checklist where before
you deploy like do we meet the criteria
we have designed thank you very much as
we've got into this area of the private
sector and Commercial pressures for
development I'm going to bring
embarrassed Ducey who wants to explore
this in a bit more detail and then I'll
follow up with Lord Gro Kart if that's
okay um I'm interested to know what do
you consider to be the role of the
private sector in driving development of
AWS and shaping Norms around their
development and deployment and how do
you think the government can encourage
responsible Innovation by the private
sector could we start with you please
answer
thanks so I think I'm I'm going to
follow up on my previous point in a
sense web is um there's a difference
between acting in the civilian sector
and Military sector so when we talk
about the private sector it's important
to be specific whether we're talking
about defense companies or civilian
companies that many operate on the
civilian Market
typically like with the way technology
is developed is when we talk about
weapon Technologies they are developed
by defense companies so like people like
companies that are pure players on
defense Market there are established
kind of relationship with with the
defense Ministries and they are
generally aware of the requirement that
the government plays on the in terms of
safety in terms of I also need to kind
of develop system without can be used in
compliance with the law and so on but
the challenge is that
now a lot of the Innovation is coming
from the civilian side and we see a
trend where uh now governments also
considering approaching a civilian
companies because they are leading
innovation in many areas
so I think this that on that that's a
kind of a novel Dynamic right
um so in a way like what we see is a is
a model where Innovation is being pulled
by the civilian sector and now the
military space trying to kind of find a
way to kind of adopt these civilian
development in a way that is helpful for
military purposes on their
there are a lot of challenges for the
military including like how do we ensure
that what works in the city business is
actually also work in the military
contexts and then you end up facing a
very practical problems like you can't
train the system with the same type of
data in the civilian sector not in the
military sector where for obvious
security reasons like you want to you
know it's it's you need different type
of data you need to be sure that the
data is properly selected and so on so
there are the Safety and Security
standards are much higher and then
that's that's a practical hurdle to
importing the technology in the military
sector
but that being said
um
it also depends on the actors so some
actors may be that states that are
responsible will do what it takes to
ensure that when they are importing
Technologies from the civilian sector
that the things was important in a way
that is responsible so that
properly tasted it uh maybe
modified it in a way so that it can be
used lawfully and safely and so on like
a set effect for use and that the user
will be trained on so on but there's
also the risk that some actors are
irresponsible and don't see you need to
be responsible and rather see the you
know the benefit of using the technology
is greater than using it safely on that
that's a challenge where when we talk
about real estate actors or potentially
some states that just four strategy
increases don't you need
to to you know adopt the technical in a
responsible way and that's that's a race
to bottom in terms of safety that is
potentially a challenge thank you
Charlie have you got anything to add and
could you just also um tell me if you
feel that the military are putting
sufficient resources behind Ai and in
particular AWS
uh sure well I'll start by say just
agreeing with Bonsai I think he raised a
number of very very important points
there
to deal with the first part of the
question I think it's also very
important to recognize that
essentially all of the leading Cutting
Edge development in the AI sector is
coming from the private sector or coming
from Academia so these are is where the
Dual use nature becomes incredibly
important I hope we do get an
opportunity to really dig into the tevv
the training evaluation verification
validation issue also apply like that
very briefly but I think that might be a
preserving of a question area of its own
so it is important to recognize also
that the nature of modern development
often compartmentalizes the engineers
who are involved and can make it very
difficult for them to follow their
second and third order consequences of
the decisions made in development the
reason I flag that is because as Bonsall
said this is effectively a relatively
novel Dynamic and it means that not only
are we having a situation where
Technologies are being developed in the
civilian environment that may then be
used in a military context including AWS
but decisions made by people at
relatively Junior levels in private
sector organizations can have
significant second and third order
impacts so some of that can be to do
with things like the training data in
question but some it can also be to do
with the parameters involved in
selecting something so we do have to be
aware of what the longer or larger
impacts those decisions can be this is
part of why Norm generation and the
development of norms is incredibly
important
so just to finish very quickly on that
first point on the private sector in the
government's role I think this is an
area that really does need to be
underlined there are a number of
Civilian focused responsible AI efforts
that I'm sure you're already familiar
with that tend to deal with issues like
algorithmic bias and they tend to look
at things in a Justice context or
similar
but they tend to have primarily a
civilian Focus what are the civilian
sector impacts of those decisions what
the civilian sector impacts algorithmic
bias which means they don't necessarily
respond to peace and security challenges
which can be related but can be
significantly different or can have
significantly more serious impacts so
the question is also how do we expand
responsible Innovation to cover peace
and security this is an area where
government encouragement could be really
helpful as the government is also the
source for the development of so much
good practices and Norms around
responsible development deploying
practices in general for those of us who
use systems like prince2 which I the
correct me if I'm wrong I understand
it's developed by the British government
these are models that become standard
good practice without necessarily having
any formal International regulation
around them
just to give a very uh brief answer on
your question about military devotion of
resources to responsible generation
obviously from a un perspective I can't
speak specifically to the British
military or the situation in general
there are steps that have been that seem
useful there are ones like the dod
principles from last year in the U.S
context there's things that are
developed by NISD which is the standards
framework organization in the US as well
that are all relevant for both civil and
Military contexts
it's very difficult to say what would be
sufficient in this kind of case so
certainly it's something that military
seem to be paying attention to but I
think it's also important to underline
the point Bonsai alluded to about the
legal requirements and I'm sure we'll
get to this later but things like
article 36 weapon reviews require a
certain standard or require certain
process to be gone through before
something could be legally deployed and
used and I think that's a key area to
look at as well
okay thank you Jasmine yeah um so
there's a lot of Dimensions to these
questions and um first I'd like to Echo
the points that Charlie and vonson both
made on the Dual use nature of
Technologies I think that beyond the
sort of classical technologies that you
would naturally that you would
instinctively think they have dual use
nature for example facial recognition
Technologies we have to even go beyond
um looking at these Technologies of one
example is some time ago I think it was
a few months ago or even just a year ago
there was an organization Belling cat
that found information on U.S nuclear
weapons station in Europe for database
from from an application on mobile
phones on flash for flashcards and the
thing is that it's because staff and
military bases were using this app to
memorize information uh Without Really
realizing that their input about these
nuclear weapon systems would go public
into the database of this app and the
thing is that we saw recently I think it
was last week that chargpt
um you know the chatbot application they
they they have established plugins where
you can basically train the system to
databases on the internet so
technically if we think about child GPT
being plugged into the database of this
flashcards app you can actually ask
this.gpt can you tell me where the
nuclear weapons are um in Europe can you
tell me some specificities about it and
you have a lot of security implications
around this kind of um blurring between
civilian applications of AI and Military
applications and then second on the
question of shaping Norms we have to be
careful about the language that we're
using because if we think
if we go from the basis that Norms are
international law rules public
international law is fundamentally made
by States and four states
does the private sector have influence
on this on the shaping of international
probably that that's something I believe
and like in terms of the standards in
terms of the non-binding instruments in
terms of the technological progress that
influences the way uh the law is shaped
but the thing is that um even beyond the
military uh sector uh we can look for
example
um in the U.S where uh you have a set of
soft law but even if the if there even
if they're negotiating bills and ads
that would be binding there would be
more prone to a self-regulatory approach
where uh basically companies are left to
themselves to basically marking their
own homeworks and they have their own
responsibility to
um to respect the the law whereas in the
EU it's much more uh generalist it's
more prescriptive and it's more a
risk-based approach where does the UK
stand there I think that um that's
something that we could discuss in world
digital in later on in term but but the
thing is that essentially we need to be
careful because in the end public
International or International
humanitarian law those are all
state-centric and even if we have
individual responsibility in the
criminal law um realm and even if we
think about domestic responsibility and
liability of these Technologies we have
to make sure that when we shape
International arms Norms if we do around
AI in weapon systems we have to make to
take into account State responsibility
and in terms of push for responsibility
there's a mismatch appearing here isn't
there because obviously International
humanitarian law needs to be enforced on
an international basis and developed on
an international basis but there's also
a role for individual governments being
able to create a regulatory environment
and enforce it now the extent to which
they can enforce it of course is an open
question but there is a role there for
individual governments Opera raging
Independence here
yeah and that's actually where you know
the
uh you have this sort of mismatch I said
the thing is states have a
responsibility
for uh for you know bodies such as the
military acting on their behalf to
respect the law because otherwise they
could be liable for violence violations
of international law
um just a quick point on the push for
responsible Innovation there's two
things that I think I would I would like
to point out first is um there's a
there's a space here for the government
to encourage an anticipatory approach to
governance so focusing on the Upstream
stages of the the life cycle of the
technology so that they would be
compliant with legal and ethical Norms
by Design I think that that's one
approach to a push for responsible
development of AI and second is we need
to acknowledge the experimental nature
of AI and the risks associated with this
experimental nature so we have to think
of incentives
and also effective approaches to take
into account this experimental nature I
think that one analogy that Chatham
House would like to uh would like we're
currently exploring for AI is the
approach that the U.S Food and Drug
Administration are adopting for products
related to Food and Drug safety so that
would be based on the phased and gradual
rollout of products and then even after
the the sort of release of the product
in the public then you have constant
auditing
um to look at the direct and the side
effects of this of this product so that
you can make sure that if things start
to go wrong and that you can see from
the expense that from this from you know
the experimental release of this product
then you can potentially phase it out
can we pause that there is easy do you
need to come back on this no I'll come
back later right
um no Fairfax
um and then I'll come to Lord Gray Court
very much
um in view of all the considerations
that all three of you have outlined this
morning is it your view that aai arms
race is realistically inevitable
Yasmine you've you've been sketching out
for us um the sort of pan glossian
approach to this it'll all be all right
in the end I'm not sure how many
supporters you have around the table but
uh what
what's your view on an arms race
I think that you
know them is that we have this
this hype run AR
Marshall civilian sector you have this
arms race Dynamic and this sort of urge
to innovate and to deploy Technologies
to to have a sort of Cutting Edge
advantage and in the military sphere I
don't think that we're spare from this
dynamic in the sense that for example
you can see in in Ukraine there is the
deployment of Technologies reportedly
from palantir and Clear View that are
based on AI and the thing is that
these are highly experimental
Technologies and I don't doubt that
whether it's like-minded States or even
adversaries they might want to deploy
similar Technologies for um in the
battlefield as a response to this sort
of
deployment of AI in the battlefield now
so you know the thing is it's
I wouldn't say it's inevitable in the
sense that yeah I mean I'm quite
skeptical in the sense that we can
refrain ourselves from an armed service
Dynamic but I think that if we
if we adopt a careful approach whether
it's to regulatory measures or even um
through soft law and policy documents I
think that there is room to refrain
ourselves from being carried over by the
hype and so at the moment you're a
cautious pessimist
um
also a cautious pessimist
I mean on that question
um I mean we looked in that topic a
while back for a report and
I don't personally don't like so much
with the concept I mean it's very catchy
and it's normal people use it but the
idea of it's a misnomer to say AI arms
race in a sense
we try to introduce idea like it's AI
capability race in a sense the race is
about
meaning about they all mean Global major
Community powers that see the value of
AI for future military capabilities
so I guess but they understood that
where
the races is at the at the level of the
building blocks
data so to ensure that you collect and
you're able to kind of develop the data
to train very Advanced AI systems so
that's 1.2 the talents it's also being
able to train enough people to actually
develop AI application be it for
civilian or military application
and third they also access to kind of
the the hardware component so this whole
idea like you need some semiconductors
that are designed specifically for
instance for machine learning and then
where we see that in where the
capability rate is playing out that is
around for instance the only discussion
about export control where
the Us and other countries see the you
know the need to kind of place some
restrictions on specific technologies
that would you know limit the ability of
China for instance to to to keep up in
the kind of capability race around
around AI so this idea of like trying to
slow down competitors by preventing them
access to the you know the key
Technologies and so on and we also see
move around this idea of like oh
preventing other countries or other
actors to access data or so on so I
think that's where we see we see
potentially like a competition going on
around like these components for for
developing advanced advanced AI and and
the second point in terms of the risk
around this kind of capability series I
think enough like that before is the um
is the prospect of having a race to the
bottom where some actors uh because they
they want to be able to kind of like
embrace the benefits of AI forming and
capabilities will disregard uh Norms
around
um you know agile compliance or safety
and decide to deploy
um AI based systems that are unsafe not
properly designed and then that could
you know if using out conflict could
expose civilian to harm or increase the
risk of escalation and so on so I think
that's that's the kind of the real kind
of security concern around that
competition that some actors will just
adopt in responsibly just because they
feel that the urge to kind of keep up
I think we all recognize that um arms
race is a rather lazy shorthand but that
it shares the phenomenon shares a lot of
characteristics with arms races as we
have come to observe them
um Charlie you're in the business I
would guess of trying to make us a bit
more optimistic about these issues
um could you do you want to reassure us
as it were fairly briefly I've got my
eye on the clock and we've still got
quite a lot of ground to cover
I'll be as reassuring as they possibly
can be and I would take that perspective
but look we have had arms races and
security alignment situations before
that we have avoided as a planet and
that we have been able to step back from
so I wouldn't call it inevitable in that
sense I do completely agree with the
points that Yasmine and bonsar Raves and
I think an important thing to underline
and again getting back to the Dual use
nature the technology and this idea of
having arms race potential Dynamics in
the building of capacity is that even
given the nature of the technology a
capacity that is grouplessly billion may
be perceived by neighbors as a kind of
latent military capacity so even if to
some degree if we're talking about a
focus that is exclusively developing a
significant domestic AI capacity it will
have an impact and one other area just
like to thank very briefly in there is
also this issue of to some degree a kind
of jurisdictional fragmentation so the
nature of the companies that we've
mentioned before dut means that not
necessarily all of those aspects are
located within a single jurisdiction so
whether we're talking about where the
data is collected where the servers are
those kind of things so given time I'll
hand back there and of course
jurisdiction shopping is always going to
be an option for some conglomerates yeah
um law grow cot if I come to you and
then Lord Horton after that uh yes I
wonder if the ask our witnesses to help
the committee by giving giving us their
how they would Define Autumn autonomous
Weapons Systems because we've found a
number of different attempts at that uh
so far if and obviously the briefer the
better but let's should we start with
you um Charlie
sure well this will be a difficult one
to be brief on but I can give a quick uh
summary which is especially from the
perspective of my office could be
because we provide the substantive
support to the group of governmental
experts in this area Gigi that I'm sure
you're familiar with there isn't an
internationally agreed definition so
there are debates around the extent to
which a definition is useful and there's
different calls for proposals around
characterizations or whether an
international agreed definition is even
needed or whether a characterization is
better one of the general points of
convergence does seem to be that a
definition characterization or
description should be technology neutral
and I think we've mentioned this briefly
before so they can adequately cover all
future types of weapons weapon systems
so something that describes the
functions and capacities of weapons or
the weapon system and centers around the
elements of autonomy human control which
I'm sure we'll get to again soon and
terms which are really at the core of
what we're actually talking about when
we debate because the technological or
technical definition maybe is not
necessarily completely required or
useful I think a good illustration is
that the the npt for example the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty as far as I'm
aware doesn't discreetly Define what a
nuclear weapon is because it doesn't
necessarily need to
so on this point the GG has already been
relatively clear that human
responsibility for decisions on the use
of weapon systems must be retained
because it cannot be transferred to
machines and these kinds of elements are
useful definitionally I think it's also
probably worth recognizing that a rigid
definition even at a domestic level that
may later become an obstacle to joining
an international instrument may also not
be advisable I'll probably just finish
by also taking a step back further and
noting that definitions of AI and
autonomy as I'm sure the committee has
found are also not universally accepted
in general to some degree AI can be a
sort of moving goal post committee
members may be familiar with not about
it long ago if there was an AI that
could reliably beat a human at chess
that would have been accepted as a
meaningful definition of AI in the
current environment that's effectively
useless
so
[Music]
thank you I'll try to be very brief
since I mentioned that before the
working definition that we use
um is which in a way reflects a lot of
the working definitions that are out
there recognize that what makes autumnus
plant feels unique is the fact that once
activated we can identify select and
apply Force to Target without human
intervention
um
we we think that's that's the most kind
of you know productive working
definition and it's not to say that it's
the diffusion that needs to be used for
potential regulation definitions of a
political you know component of it so
but I guess for the kind of the legal or
ethical or security analysis I think
this these are the important elements if
I may I can maybe add a few additional
elements that are usually associated
with in terms of characteristic with
autonomous weapons
hey I think it's good to remember that
AWS can take all shape and form and be
equipped with very different type of
payloads and they're using very
different type of missions and conflicts
so that's one of the challenge in the
debate like people think of different
type of Optimus weapons some people
think of high intensity type of drones
that will you know fight like you know
machine speed overall thinking of of
more like Contour Insurgency uh models
where we are trying to kind of track
down terrorist groups somewhere in the
cave totally different application but
the another characteristic which is I
think important for the analysis is that
it's a it's a pre-programmed weapon and
what makes problems what is different
from all the guide elimination is the
idea that you program the weapon to
attack Target types or categorize your
targets rather than a specific human you
know specific design Target so say these
categories of Tanks rather than that
specific tank in that specific location
and it needs like that's a third
characteristic that it's a it's a Target
activated weapon so once the you know
once in the environment once that's
recognized the type of Target to engage
it will engage automatically the human
doesn't need to press a button
that being said full characteristic the
human may be in a supervisory role and
keep the opportunity to override the
system but it will not it doesn't need
to to kind of have the system can only
implement the targeting cycle
automatically
that's so just to say the human can be
in supervisable and we can still be
Electronics weapons in my view
look very good yeah
what what I tried so much of this is
speculative
um almost academic these kind of
discussions I'm finding so uh you all
have difficulties in defining AWS or at
least that seems to be a pretty
consistent problem throughout the whole
of these discussions
um but what I'd like to can you actually
pincer whatever however you define it
could you please give me an example of
an existing weapons system that either
meets the um definition that you've got
or comes close to meeting it I'd just
like to get something going to get my
hands on
Ali let's so well it doesn't matter
Jasmine
so I will not be able to provide a
specific example of an autonomous weapon
systems or an AI enable weapon system
but there is evidence that there are
other
app military applications of AI enable
systems used in the battlefield for
example we have reports around uh the
use of
technology developed by Clear View so
it's a company uh in Ukraine to identify
uh dead bodies and which you know is in
line in principle with International
humanitarian law um uh sort of
requirements to you know dispose of the
dead but then the thing is that um it's
based on facial recognition Technologies
and that's established as an AI
um but whether or not but you know I
would not say it's a working system
because then it's used for other other
functions
um there are reports that palantir are
using AI enabled Technologies to help
with targeting to select Targets in in
Ukraine I think I'm still very I think
Luke gray Cobbs really after something
uh very specific here you know to point
to a piece of Hardware that fits into
one category or not I mean we we're very
well aware of some of the developments
you've described but this seems to be
the Block in our route to understanding
and appreciating exactly what we're
talking about
if I may come in here
um
I mean some there are there are a few
historical examples of automated weapon
systems and according to the division
that we use could also be uh described
as autonomous weapon systems to the
extent that once activated it can select
and engage Target without an
intervention these are typically
defensive weapon systems and there are
versions of them so for instance you
have the Phalanx closing weapon system
which is particular system that we have
on the ship which is can be turned into
autonomous mode if there is like a
oncoming like overwhelming attack the
system will just automatically identify
incoming threats and try to neutralize
them so be there like Misa incoming
missiles or incoming planes and so on
you have the same version also for like
tanks it's called active protective
systems also it's a system that you
activate an autonomous mode and if there
are incoming threats to the tank he will
try to identify the Munitions and
neutralize them that's for this type of
defensive systems that have been around
for a very long time
they can also be in a mode where it's
supervised and the human may be your
mother White's kind of semi-autonomous
when you would authorize the the use of
force but it can be turned into a fully
autonomous mode the other type more
offensive type of weapons to the one
that is closest to what people are
actually concerned with are what we call
loitering munitions so basically it's a
mix between a drone and a missile and if
the idea is that you would have
um like the hoppy that was developed in
Israel in the 90s but there have been
other development semen you know over
the last decades uh in similar systems
on the development
and the idea is that you you send the
drone over a specific area and you have
it loiter over that area to find
the type of Target that is supposed to
attack and originally that was designed
for
suppression of any air defenses so the
harpy the men the one I mention
basically it's supposed to kind of go
find Mobile Radars so the problem with
the mode that really does is that you
don't always know where they are they
are switched on they're emit for a
limited period and then we switch off so
the idea of having a lighter ammunition
is that it can over over that area and
as soon as it detects the radar is then
basically destroyed on on that radar
that has been around for a very long
time and now we see that potential
development of Glory to emissions that
will also be used against other type of
targets like tanks and so on
um and then I've been research project
I've tried to look at that for for a
long time
but an interesting anecdote is that when
these distance were developed in the 90s
originally they were supposed to before
the autonomous in the sense well once
it's to Fire and forget once it's sent
the system will just do the thing you
will not be able to read what you could
call it
but the new versions of a time I've been
equipped with actually remote control
where the operator can keep the
possibility to steer the system and I
bought the mission so I think it's an
interesting
uh development in a sense that we don't
see necessarily like a trajectory
towards more autonomy but system work
militaries we still want to keep some
control over the weapon if possible I
think we're moving very neatly into the
area of human involvement which I know
is something Lord Horton wants to pursue
yeah good good morning and thank you for
spend spending time with us this morning
um can I also ask you to be helpful to
the committee here not cautionary but
very positive in making some
recommendations about human involvement
um I say that because I can I don't
think that the committee's problem is
really anything to do with ethics or
morality or compliance with IHL I think
we we could probably all sit degree
qualifications in them the amount of
evidence on those things that we're
taking our problem is the challenge of
how best to comply
while still maximizing all the benefits
of AI that we know are out there and
which was that's why you mentioned
earlier on those things that relate to
to cost
precision and
no human military casualties potentially
um so from my perspective there are
probably three routes to compliance
which certainly don't involve the
creation of new law one of them that
you've mentioned is selective regulatory
bans on the basis of legality or on the
basis of the fact that these systems
employ a black box technology which is
not understandable by even the experts
that develop it
the second route would be to place
technical limits on the degree of
autonomy on a fielded system so that at
some point there was human involvement
in the chain
and then the third if you like is any
enhancements to what I would call
Battlefield regulations
because after all the battlefield is
highly regulated already in respect to
Rules of Engagement targeting directives
command and controlled protocols
so the question really is about
translating policy into operational
reality
and to make this possible within the UK
policy guidelines thus far
um we have got to have appropriate human
involvement or meaningful human control
in relation to AWS and
could you
um
give your own understanding of those
terms and perhaps indicate some
beneficial ways in which human
involvement might be brought about
can I start with vanson
yeah I'm happy to break the ice um so
thank you for the question I think I'll
start with the first concept that you
mentioned like context appropriate human
involvement
um
so for me these 10 recognize two things
a that or an attack with AWS
avoid to be lawful the human should be
involved to determine
and help ensure that the effect of that
attack
are not prohibited on the international
law and also complying with the rules
guiding the collective hostilities
principle of Distinction and
proportionality and precaution
that that formulation also recognized
that the way and the extent to which
human needs to be involved may vary
that's the context element right
depending on contextual variables so
notably like the the actual
characteristic of the systems how
predictable it might be how you can
recognize the target but also the
characteristic on the environment are
predictable the environment is how is
the other civilians or civilian objects
that are present to what extent or to a
civilians May pop up at some point
during the operation also so I think
this is what that term is supposed to
kind of like capture in practice now
moving on to the concept of meaning for
human control so I guess you all know
like the term was originally coined by a
civil society you know a UK based NGO
called article 36 and it had become a
very popular term in the policy
conversation because it kind of capture
the idea that humans should keep agency
over the decision to to use phones and
that their role should remain meaningful
and and I think the point of adding that
qualifier meaningful is that
having human interest in your
supervisory rule might not be enough uh
not only because of problem like we know
of like automation biased
so you mentioned you should in a way you
exercise some kind of an actual to
ensure legal compliance but also
potentially ethical acceptability but
also ensuring that you know the mission
is actually like uh efficient from the
military perspective but at the same
time it's also important to acknowledge
that the the term meaningful you might
control is a compass determine the
policy conversation uh for a number of
reasons I think one I think the key
reason for for we found is that
corrected is that some actors are
concerned that the word control could be
interpreted in a very narrow way and be
equated to this idea of actually active
control over the weapon at all times
because for some of its actions like
this idea of this form of control is not
is not appropriate and or like it's not
I not legally required but also Me Maybe
counterproductive in some contexts and
might actually lead to more casualty
um
so then in terms of like if I don't know
if you want me to elaborate on how you
know this time could be uh you know
basically exercise in practice but when
it comes to kind of exercising
appropriate human involvement
based on the work that we
you know we have done the ideas that uh
the involvements that means that the
human should kind of try to exercise
some form of judgment to determine
whether the you know in light of the
characteristic environment whether the
effects you know Aid in system can be
directed at the military objective and
that the effect will be compliant with
the distinction proportionality and also
depending on different variables that
the user will may need to take
precautionary measures so for instance
you could decide not to deploy that
weapons because the risk are too high or
you could then try to use different type
of control measures to kind of limit the
effect to ensure that the effects are
awful and there I think our view is that
it's important to see that under the
notion of control like there are a lot
of different possibilities
the first one is like you know it's you
know you can try to work with the weapon
parameters in the design phase for
instance by by limiting the type of
light so I guess that the system can
engage how high it may recognize the
target you can at the moment of
activation you can also try to limit the
scope of operation in terms of time and
space so like not not loitering for like
three hours because only like 10 minutes
to reduce the risk of breakability for
instance
that's one type of control measures
another type is the idea of having
control over the environment so you can
try to directly try to structure the
environment to minimize the risk of
Civic casualties for instance where you
issue warning or you put some fences to
make clear activities to not be or
accessing that that area that could be
the case for instance if you are using
the no man's land area or if you're
using autonomous weapon to protect a
specific perimeter like a base or
something
and third the third type of measures is
the one obviously people almost focused
on is this human machine interaction
types and in some contexts it might be
needed for a human to remain in a
supervisory role and keep their ability
to intervene to minimize the risk of
engagement on its proportionate effects
so these are the basic three big
categories that we identified in our
work
of a challenge well
yeah I think Bonsai has been pretty
comprehensive as well I think it's
important to touch on that issue of the
environment itself so the example of
online game before on phthala is a
relatively uncontroversial system
because it's intended to be used at Sea
so it's an environment where there
shouldn't really be civilians present
I think it's important to recognize that
it hasn't been demonstrated that any
algorithm can reliably make the
human-like decisions and judgments
required to comply with international
law and the many states have argued that
no weapon system using our autonomy and
its critical functions can perform those
judgments in Conformity with
International humanitarian law so I mean
from our side the Secretary General has
been pretty clear that he says machines
with the power and discretion to take
lives without human involvement are
politically unacceptable morally
repugnant and should be prohibited by
international law I'm sure you're
already familiar with the Lions one that
we use a lot he was referring
specifically to weapons that could be
used to Target an attack without any
involvement control or oversight of
human operator
so
article 36 weapons reviews have come up
again
um I think this is an area that we
certainly wish to explore further than
we would encourage states to share good
practices in their weapons for you
processes in this context and especially
to support other states but I think it's
also important just to add to what we've
heard is that it may also be useful to
think what the implications for AWS are
and other uses of military AI what the
implications are for their use in this
context if their compliance cannot be
satisfactorily assessed so what would be
the implications for use and regulations
if you can't demonstrate that they can
be used so in addition to the points
that also has made I think it's
important to underline that before I
come to Yasmine can you just be clear on
that that um
you almost give the impression that
there can be no human delegation to a
fully autonomous system but if that
fully autonomous system has been tested
and approved and such a way that it
doesn't rely on a black box technology
but constant evaluation has proved that
the risk of it
non-complying with the parameters of
human of international humanitarian law
are accepted that then there is a
delegation effectively from a human to a
machine why is that not
then compliant or why would you say that
that should be prohibited
so again as I'm coming from un side I
would be deferring to member states for
what the end decisions are for a total
prohibition or what any kinds of uh
International instruments were but I
think the key issue there is that that's
a very big if if it is possible to
demonstrate all of those things testing
evaluation verification and validation
have come up for a good reason that the
environment of testing for civilian AI
can be incredibly similar to the
environment deployment for civilian AI
for an autonomous weapon system we have
to think what could the testing
environment possibly be like that would
make us as in in this case your
committee make you satisfied that
definitely the system would behave in
that specific way when used in the
environment deployment and I think when
you talk about delegation I think the
issue there is also just accountability
so if those things were able to be
demonstrated if you were able to have a
system that had no black box element
that was completely explainable we could
completely understand why the decisions
were made there still needs to be an
element of human accountability so it's
that part that is the part that we would
wish to underline so and what I'm saying
is that there still is human
accountability because a human has take
ultimately a politician a government
Minister has delegated through a
targeting directive the fact that he is
content to delegate to this particular
piece of autonomous Machinery in certain
circumstances that it can act on its own
predetermined algorithms or whatever so
long as they're not a black box that
nobody can understand
in that case then the person making that
decision would be legally responsible
absolutely consequences of decisions as
Government ministers are all the time
about the authorization of lethal Force
it's one of their duties
I think there's also a question there
and this will probably come up again in
other sessions that you have of how
accountable that person can be to the
extent they understand or reasonably
could be expected to understand
the
deviations that the system might make so
I think the to go back to what I was
saying before the main issue there is
that it's a very big if how would we
demonstrate all of those things so how
would we ensure that the politician in
this case or whether it was a military
officer in other cases is reasonably
informed and could reasonably expect the
system to behave in the way that it does
but then if it doesn't behave in the
intended function that person is still
it's reasonable to hold them accountable
I'm tempted to observe that in this
respect
sometimes the human being is probably as
vulnerable to not getting it right as
the machine but anyway that's a
different set of answers let's go to
Yasmin and they'll give word to someone
else yeah so of course the thing is that
there will be situations where human
involvement oversight approval control
or whatever term we're using would be
more desirable or even necessary for
compliance with international law um
against like the technical capabilities
and limitations of of the of the
technology that we're talking about so
for example Target engagement in areas
with densely civil civilian population
or
um with high heightened risks of this
disproportionately visual civilian
casualties but then on the flip side of
the coin as you rightly pointed out
there are some situations that may
require such speed that the cognitive
limitations of human beings may actually
constitute more of a liability for
illegal compliance and the question is
that accountability is not necessary the
question in the sense that there will
always be a human accountable that
that's for sure it's more a question of
choosing the appropriate contexts in
which a human there would be more more
benefits than risks of deploying AI that
may have certain levels of human control
or not and in the end it's a question of
risk assessments and
and the calculation of risk versus
opportunities whether it's related to
Mission success but also legal
compliance and compliance with moral and
ethics and policy and one way of sort of
working around this sort of the issue
that Charlie mentioned about the
reasonable expectation to understand how
the technology works and the ability to
operate human control when necessary is
the question of the design stages of the
of the technology so when we
conceptualize an AI system we have to
think is it really worth doing um
delegating this kind of tasks during AI
or is it more worth keeping it within
the realm of human of human human
intervention and if it's actually worth
using AI then we have to work around the
technical parameters of the technology
but also the interface that is being
used because in the end and users might
not have a computer science background
that might not have been involved in the
coding and the design and the testing
and evaluation stages of the technology
they're just being handed the technology
and one way to sort of ensure that they
can exercise the human intervention or
control in the appropriate context is
that is to make sure that these
interfaces are user friendly and in a
way that would enable them to to be
aligned with these legal Norms uh I I
was talking the other day with someone
um from from a technology company
specifically developing software for
helping with targeting and one of the
solutions they found was for example to
have the screen and then um you have a
pop-up that comes up and freezes all
decision making until a human a human
operator would actually say yes or no
this is a this is a awful Target
you know it's this kind of Technical
Solutions and interface that I think
would be helpful in terms of
operationalizing this on the exercise of
human control when appropriate but it
kind of just helps Germany this um issue
that keeps uh arising as to whether the
technology does what it's intended to do
I mean that's not specific to AI is it I
mean that that's the characteristic of
the you know obeying it either works or
it doesn't work I mean if it bends when
you're using it it's not much use and I
mean is isn't that just an assumption
when you look at any weapon or any
weapon system of course I mean if you
look at for example offensive cyber
capabilities you're sort of going with
the assumption that this capability will
work as intended I will not for example
uh will not for example go beyond the
targeted systems that are that that it
is intended to be offensive against or
whether it's related to missile missile
systems or missile Technologies or other
other kind of Technology of course like
and that's why I think AI is a lot about
novel questions but also old questions
related to for example technical
reliability
and can we move on to a broader stage
perhaps the bishop of Coventry thank you
Lord chair and thank you very much for
uh to uh to our Witnesses
um it's uh it's always fascinating to
follow Lord Horton
um uh my my questions are are sort of on
the same theme but but that of a much
more amateur sort I'm always fascinated
to hear Lord Horton talk about uh
Commander uh uh responsibility and
Battlefield regulation
um I suppose what I'm finding it quite
difficult to get my mind round with
um AWS is if I understand it right
an element of the definition is
adaptability to the environment
Amazon Jasmine said earlier taking on
board uh Battlefield data
and therefore
I I I'm finding it very difficult to see
how Hume meaningful human involvement
can be integrated into and evolving
weapon system
how does the commander
who and I may be mistaken but picking up
your comment a moment ago Yasmine
may not have uh you know
the technical expertise always uh that
that others would have at different
stages of the development how would that
commander in an evolving situation with
an evolving weapon
um be able to calibrate the
um the the right sort of human
involvement you know would it change as
the weapon changes
and if I may ask and this is a sort of
bigger supplementary I suppose one thing
I think we've been well I've certainly
been very interested in I think has been
a regular theme has been the sort of
um well we're not there yet theme as it
were
um that um
uh the the Weaponry is simply uh notable
and I think they'll saw you sort of it
you know referred to this a moment ago
the weapon or maybe was it Charlie that
the Weaponry simply isn't to the point
at which it can be trusted to uh you
know to to meet the requirements of
international law
but I'm also very conscious as as
Jasmine said you know the speed at which
it's developing you said you can't keep
up with it my my goodness none of us can
um and so I suppose I'm I'm wondering
how we handle that
um and and how
um policy makers and law makers and even
and and the military
think forward to those situations that
may not be
as far away as we've been sort of
assured they will be so I suppose I'm
thinking in terms of the reassuring sort
of comments that our military defense
make that yes weapons that really are
you know autonomous have made their own
decisions and so on we just don't want
anything to do with them I mean you know
in the in in the sort of very Advanced
State
um but we needn't worry about that
because that's a long way off
um do we not have to be prepared for the
long way off that might be nearer than
when we first you know than we might
anticipate so there's a very big
question there
um uh maybe the first one if you were
able to focus on that is is in but I
think the second one relates to it as
well but this whole question of
self-evolving
um uh weapons and how human
responsibility
um
you know what that means in that and I
think that does relate to the speed of
development because these things are
changing so quickly and the capacity to
self-evolve I guess is is is is
increasing all the time
um thank you and forgive our other uh
long uh settled questions um it looks as
if you're wanting to come in on that
thanks I mean you you raise a number of
very uh vegan and interesting questions
um I guess to our point that is
important to
um to keep in mind is is related to the
kind of notion of adaptability
I think sometimes we tend to kind of
like confuse the idea that the weapon
maybe adapt to to a
dynamic situation and variations in in
the environment and the ability to keep
to learn and to change its programming
so uh the the first option might be fine
as long as we can predict and have an
idea of how the system May or not adapt
to variations for instance like weather
variations or whether like you know
changing like if there's a presence of
civilians or not and whether the system
will be able to kind of trigger a
different type of response you know in a
way that can be pre-programmed and
controlled in in some way where you can
still have some kind of predictability
You can predict that system will be a
specific way in a specific uh if this
happens basically
um but then if when we are talking about
a system that would keep learning and
taking in new data and and re-changing
their parameters of views during the use
then then that would be problematic and
actually people would argue that this
weapon would be inertly unlawful because
you will need to do a new legal review
to verify that the learning has not
affected the performance in a way that
would make the effect indiscriminate by
Nature
so in a sense that people would argue
that
if there is some learning most likely
there will be in a form of like the
system learn doing the mission after the
mission the the information is uploaded
and then uh retested and reassessed and
then the system can go but he would have
to go through some form of a screening
process otherwise that's that would be
legally problematic but also for seeing
that commanders would find that uh they
wouldn't want a system to use a system
where they they don't know how the
system might behave or might learn
something that could lead the system to
behaving a way that is unpredictable and
then either I could lead to kind of a
civilian harm or
just a situation where it would be
operation you can just uh just you know
contract it so this would be the the
main two points and then it's perhaps
just to add one last point and to go
back to the IHL question
because I think it's an important
element this dishonest I think growing
understanding is that
weapons we should not entrepromatize
um Optimus weapons weapons do not comply
with the law the law bites on States and
you know their agents human agents so so
the responsibility to comply with HR is
with the states that and the armed
forces that decide to deploy weapons so
that in a sense like the evaluations
demanded for instance by the principles
distinction proportionality cannot be
fully automated in a sense that humans
ultimately or the Agents of the states
need to make these decisions I think
that's one of the interpretation that is
you know
fairly shared by uh by in the in the
community of legal legal advisors
thank you very much that's very helpful
and and the whole concept of Weapons
review I know Tony has spoken about I
suppose I'm also interested though in
whether
um am I right in thinking that the
weapon May May so adapt
in the in the usage of the moment
um that it becomes something different
and therefore is problematic from a con
human involvement point of view
um Charlie any further thoughts
yeah I would second the points of my
sunrise and in relation to your
follow-up question yes I think that is
one of the issues at hand is that the
idea of a non-determinist existing the
will adapt is that it will do so in a
way that is presumably intended to be
useful in the deployment of the system
but is also adds another element of
unpredictability this is why Nelson
brings up the issue of it would
presumably have to be again tested and
evaluated at each point but it also
brings in aside from issues so Yasmine
brought this up as well of human dignity
and some of the issues that are related
around the extent to which it is
reasonable legal or appropriate to
assign some of these tasks or some of
these roles to a machine is also the
issue of adversarial action as it comes
into predictability so we've been
talking about a lot of these things
generally in the sense of if a system
behaves as we expect it to with no other
external issue but we also need to be
aware of these are all going to be
vulnerabilities presented by these kinds
of systems that makes them also
vulnerable to adverse area action that
can itself then bring in new elements of
unpredictability that ties in also to
the point that was raised of say a
bayonet and the ways that a bayonet
might fail there's a relatively narrow
range of ways that a bayonet might fail
and that a person then deploying it
could reasonably be expected to
anticipate and react to you may be
familiar with some of these examples
with self-trading vehicles and so on
where very minor changes in the pattern
of stickers that are put on a stop sign
or something mean that it's interpreted
completely differently by the autonomous
vehicle
that's without any adversarial action
you do also then need to consider
adversarial action in this context but
we then also add in addition to the
other black box and big if things that
we've covered before that an issue in
this context as well is
non-state actors from a technological
perspective are probably already in a
position to use these kinds of systems
to meet the kind of
requirements that are have been brought
up to select a Target to engage with the
target the question more on the state
side is the extent to which that's
possible and to meet the legal
requirements and to do so in a way that
meets the requirements this committee is
discussing and that's the point I was
Raising before from the UN side that
from our perspective has not been
demonstrated
thank you thank you Jasmine anything too
so in terms of the first question that
you raised that is fascinating and you
know how to sort of maintain this
meaningful human control and the light
of the adaptability the adaptable nature
of AI and also how they combine a lot of
Battlefield data I think that trickles
back to the question of interface and
you know at the risk of oversimplifying
it um when you look at navigational apps
on your phone for example Google Maps
you say you want to go from point A to
point B the thing is that it com it will
the software combine a lot of live data
from the traffic from you know bus time
tables from incidents from you know tube
strikes or whatever and then it will
provide you um a set of like a
propositionary and I think that if we
but then you can play around with the
itinerary proposed based on a set of
parameters that you have control over
and I think that you know if we take
this analogy for
um AI systems for military for military
applications are you know if we have the
appropriate parameter that will enable
the sort of the users to filter out data
that might not necessarily need to know
on the first basis but they still have
some control over the parameters and
they're able to play around with the
outcome then I think that's a that's a
that's a good solution and echoing
vonson's point on keeping up with tech
advances I think
um article 36 legal reviews are useful
um in terms of assessing the the
compliance of the systems with the law
but then it doesn't mean that once you
you've given it the green light it will
always be compliant because of its ever
evolving nature and that's why I think
that you know coming soon's Point again
um the establishment of monitoring and
auditing
um consider requirements on a constant
basis
um is it would be a useful step whether
it would be independently made or not um
conducted like the auditing system the
auditing processes that's another
question because obviously you have the
question of
um industrial secrecy and also the
extent to which the systems uh like
independent parties can play around with
the system because of its inherent
coding and obviously again around
Technical and secrecy considerations
um but then obviously you don't want
people to mark their own homeworks as
well so that that's that consideration I
would say I think we are running out of
time and uh Lord Brown the clock is
against you
do you want to come in on the I IHL
airspace
English question of some sense so um
so the questions I want to ask have been
they were anticipated I think by the
exchange between you Charlie and Lord
Houghton
um so they're about the the sufficiency
of international humanitarian law
to government I'll very carefully watch
my lamential Advance on the use of
AWS rather than the the AWS themselves
or whether we need other International
agreements or Accords and let me just
say as a comment my
influence from from
um the U.N secretary General's remarks
well that he was talking about
uh Technologies which which to me gave
the impression that he knew were likely
to be developed rather than just talking
in a vacuum when he was talking about
weapon systems that were publicly
unacceptable and uh morally Republic
morally repugnant so it suggests to me
that
he is the leader of the United Nations
believes that this issue of sufficiency
is being challenged so perhaps certainly
you could expand upon what you said
earlier to start as awfulness
sure and I think that interpretation is
correct broadly so the and this goes
back to the technological question I
raised before so from a purely
technological perspective facial
recognition other Technologies around AI
do make viable A system that can select
a Target and then engage it as in they
make it technologically viable
all of the other issues presented and
all these other ones we've covered
whether these are from the more ethical
side or even just from practical
questions around consistency
predictability training everything else
call that into question so the concern
from the Secretary General is not that
these are far off Technologies or this
is a far off potential application or
that this is something that is being
considered as purely a sort of
hypothetical in a vacuum but that we are
essentially at this point that some
weapon systems that already exist could
potentially be argued to exist within
the space whether they are used in that
sense or not and in all cases we are
certainly within the technological
threshold of being able to deploy weapon
systems that can do some of these things
or all of these things the question then
is the relevance of IHL which obviously
applies and how we can ensure compliance
both in these senses and then also some
of the questions come up or about
predictability
so there is an understanding and I
believe especially in the context of the
gge emerging that any type of weapon
that incorporates autonomies into the
functions that I've mentioned so
selecting and attacking targets should
be strictly regulated and these
regulations could include limits on
things that were brought up before so
targets and locations in which such
weapons were used
whether that comes in the form of a
international instrument or some other
form it's still an open question but the
important point is that International
humanitarian law continues to fully
apply to all weapon systems including
potential development and use of
autonomous weapon systems
we flagged before as well the issue then
that such weapons or weapon systems must
be able to be traced back to human
element to ensure accountability and
issues of dignity and some of the other
questions have come up I think this
committee is probably already familiar
with questions like the Martin's clause
and the implications of that that
essentially regardless of the state of
the technology under International Japan
it's Aaron law even in situations
without an explicit rule civilians and
combatants remain under the production
of principles derived from public
conscience I think the question is not
so much is international uh humanitarian
law is sufficient to cover we've clearly
covered lots of examples of the
relevance and importance of IHL and
international law more generally it's
how do we operationalize that and what
does that mean for the context of this
committee some of the questions I raised
before in the context of article 36
weapons reviews is to think about what
it would mean if compliance cannot be
satisfactorily assessed what does that
mean for the development of any of these
kinds of systems or what does that mean
for the development of any system that
conceivably has some of these
Technologies or capacities
so I think I would probably just want to
underline that element of it and then
I'm happy to pass on
yeah perhaps um Yasmine I mean I could
expand can I expand this this question
encouraged to do so by you in your first
answers which is
beyond the actual weapon system which uh
which is deployed for its lethality
and I mean I mean should we should we
expand this to include lethality
enabling uh systems in weapons and how
do we you know and what's your view as
to whether International humanitarian
law as presently and is presently
applied is sufficient to govern the use
of there
yeah so I think that um
I definitely think that we should be
expanding the our Thinking Beyond weapon
systems but also all systems that are
lethality enabling so for example when
you look at in on the other side of the
pond in the U.S there was this
Revelation from
um the National Security Agency having a
program that collects data from mobile
phones in a select parameter and then
based on the data um on people's mobile
phones or the location uh the call logs
Etc then they would be able to identify
um a an Al-Qaeda Courier
and the thing is that it's it's a lot
it's just based on the the roots that
the the the mobile phones are taking and
basically their itinerary would suggest
that someone is actually a career for Al
Qaeda and when they deployed uh when
they use the system they mistakenly
identified an aljazeera journalist as an
alcoholic career
you know that kind of system is not a
weapon system but it's lethality
enabling because then if you actually
engage
um the the set Target a journalist that
would absolutely be against the against
International humanitarian law
considerations so I would definitely
agree that we should be covering these
kind of Technologies whether IHL is
sufficient the thing is that the law is
there and it was designed so as to take
into account all forms of warfare even
if its nature is changing what I'm
trying to say here is that even
futuristic scenarios would be covered by
existing rules and I would be actually
careful in saying that the law is not
sufficient because then it means that
you know it would imply that there are
gaps in the law that people could be
exploiting for their own gained and that
would go against the rule of law but the
thing is that those rules are versatile
because they are General and there's a
lot of to unpack and there's a lot of
clarification that would be needed and
would be useful how it would be done
whether it's through International
processes whether it's through a treaty
whether it's through softball law
because we have also to take into
account that it's incredibly difficult
to come up with an international treaty
especially now
um in in this geopolitical context I
mean we can say for example in the
nuclear sphere how um how contentious it
was to to negotiate the Nuclear Ban
Treaty for example so you know if we
have if we take it holistically and take
into account hard law instruments and
subtle instruments and other processes
that would enable this clarification on
how the law would apply and be
operationalized against the deployment
of AI enabled systems then I think that
that would be really useful step
one final point I'm going to ask you
this question so I mean although Charlie
was the one that encouraged us to look
at article 36 is a key area and to look
at so I'm going to I'm going to ask you
if you can if you can engage with this
question right so
so
um I mean one way of testing whether the
existing rules that we have in
regulations are sufficient is to look at
article 36 are you aware of any existing
Weapons review you know of an autonomous
system which assessed that system as
being complex autonomous weapon system
as being compliant
um with International humanitarian law
and secondly I mean do all do all those
jurisdictions that carry out these
article 36 assessments publish them
I mean are the public entitled to know
what the what these reviews conclude
uh thank you uh for the question we uh
secret did a quite a lot of work in uh
in the past years on the Arctic
authorization especially in the context
of emerging Technologies and autonomous
weapons
um the first element to answer your
question is that
there is no requirement by law for
states to disclose the outcome of a
legal review
and not that it's you know they cannot
do it but Most states do not disclose
any information so to my knowledge I
can't report any case of um of of a
recent case of like a weapon review of
an Optimus weapons I have heard that
there have been weapons that have been
reviewed notably in the US
but I call you know I don't have any you
know provide any evidence the only
evidence I can say that some of the
automated weapons that we have seen
today uh like the filing systems that I
mentioned earlier already happy most
likely have been through these processes
before that's one thing so we know that
there are some weapons that share some
characteristic with autonomous weapons
that have been being lawful in the past
through uh a past these processes
and I think one element that is
important not to note with regard to the
value of that process is that
it's one critical mechanism to ensure
that the weapon can be used in
compliance but it's not the only one and
I want to stress that you know the the
actual legal purpose of article 36 and
I'm going to quote the text is to
determine whether the employment would
in some or all circumstances be
prohibited by the additional protocol
and any other role of international so I
think that's basically the first thing
that state will try to do whether like
as people at states are considering the
development or the adoption of a new
weapons whether it's actually something
that is already prohibited whether it is
it is prohibited by any specific weapon
treaty like The Logical weapon
convention or chemical weapon convention
or blending less uh treaty or any other
general rules of of international law
and if it's it's not prohibited then
potentially they can uh that will pass
the review but most likely the reviewer
would also issue some some
recommendation as with regard to
elements to be considered for the lawful
use
and these elements usually this
recommendation would be really helpful
for them designing the rule of procedure
and the rule of Engagement specific to
that type of weapon and here I want to
note another mechanism that we don't
talk often so much about but it's it's
flowing from rule 82 about the provision
of legal advice
so I shall also demand the provision of
legal advice when necessary that means
basically having legal advisors on the
side of commanders to kind of help them
assess whether the use of a specific
weapon in a specific context will be
lawful and I think in the context of
Optimus weapons that's highly important
and could be the necessary where the
commander would be supported by legal
advisors to assess whether at the moment
of activation it can it can make the
assessment that the effect will below
food or at least not be prohibited
thank you
thank you very much can I exclude
Fairfax to bring us to a conclusion
thank you thank you very much and and
with your permission may I just ask one
very quick question to answer um arising
under something you said earlier you
drew a distinction and I think you
mentioned phallax between uh offensive
and defense defensive weapons but is
that a distinction in fact irrelevant
because it's very difficult to to work
out where uh the dividing line is
between an offensive and a
defensive question and then I have a if
you just deal with that quickly and then
I have a main question for each of you
thanks no that's a very good question I
mean I would agree with you that
distinction is not very useful
especially if we are getting into the
territory of like you know policy making
and Rule making
um
it's it's useful to categorize some of
the weapons that are in use today but
obviously we definitely weapons can also
be used in an offensive way and the you
know how do you categorize the the
defensive offensive is a very uh it's
not a you know clear-cut so I agree with
you on that point yeah thank you my
question for each of you is the same
question what one recommendation would
you make to the UK government if you
could make it in this area
I think toward Fairfax may be looking
for a one sentence answer
[Laughter]
I'm happy to stop um I'll I'll keep it
in one sentence
um the UK has been very active in the
conversation in Geneva on autonomous
weapons and especially with regard to
kind of pushing for more in-depth
discussion on HL and how igl actually
applies to the development and news of
Thomas weapons and I think that's that
effort has to be commended and it's my
recommendation is that the UK should
keep
supporting this type of effort and
ensuring that there's a substantial
level the discussion is moving forward
and and trying to provide greater
clarity as to how the rules of HR needs
to be interpreted and applied in the in
the context of buttons weapons since
there are still Elements which some
respect can be open to very different
interpretations so I think it's a very
useful exercise
thank you
Charlie
oh well I'm certainly lucky that I can
take that sentence for granted and so I
would say to stress the importance of
responsibility throughout the AI
lifecycle including in the civilian
space this kind of development of norms
and best practice is something that the
UK has been traditionally quite good at
and I mentioned prince2 and other
program standards that have become
International as that uh background so
given the nature of the technology we've
emphasized the Dual use issues embedding
peace and security concerns within
normal risk management mitigation and so
on in normal AI development practices in
civilian and defense situations would be
something I would heavily recommend and
encourage the UK government to support
especially as this would be building on
good practices the UK government has
already LED on and Yasmine you're
speaking to the UK government so I
received not here but in the broader
sense
I would suggest being a careful leader
in the responsible development of AI so
I would say that focusing you know on
the Upstream stages in the Technology's
life cycle to promote compliance by
Design is one recommendation I was
stressed on of course not to Discount
the importance of past deployment stages
and across the life cycle of the
technology but I think there's a lot of
room for the UK to be to instill this
culture of safety and compliance by
Design internationally internationally
it can go a long way especially in AI in
the AI field where unfortunately legal
and ethical considerations are more of
an afterthought rather than something
deeply rooted within the response of the
research and development culture from
the earlier stages in the Technology's
life cycle that would decrease risk from
the beginning and would provide space
for them
multidisciplinary multi-stakeholder and
inclusive input from for this for the
development of this powerful
Technologies
all right well thank you very much
indeed
um
expertise and to all of you
um to Charlie and to Yasmine as well
thank you very much indeed for the time
you've spent with us this morning we've
all found it extremely helpful and as
always we will have various things to
follow up as well but thank you very
much indeed thank you